[Musik]
die mitte europas im wandel der zeit
ein land das lange braucht um eins zu
werden
menschen die sich erst im laufe der
jahrhunderte als deutsch verstehen
[Musik]
wer sind wir
woher kommen wir
fragen an die geschichte der deutschen
die mebo nutzen
die
[Musik]
für die letten
im zwölften jahrhundert rebelliert eine
frau wir werden gegen das bildest du dir
eigentlich ein
die deutsche prophetin wird hildegard
von bingen genannt
[Musik]
sie ist die bekannteste deutsche des
mittelalters medizinerin visionärin und
managerin
[Musik]
im herbst des jahres 1147 kommt papst
eugen der dritte persönlich ins reich
der deutschen
er wolle auch so heißt es über das
schicksal an einer nonne namens
hildegard entscheiden
hat er unser der du bist in kiel
geheiligt werde dein name
zu uns denn sie sei die posaune gottes
behaupten
eine anmaßung
für uns nicht versuchen
vom teufel besessen von gott auserwählt
sie lässt hat gott dem prophetin gottes
oder sprachrohr des teufels vom wort des
papstes hängt hildegard schicksal ab das
reich zu beginn des zwölften
jahrhunderts eine zeit des aufbruchs und
der erneuerung nach einer jahrhunderte
langen kälteperiode ist es endlich
wärmer und trockener geworden
[Musik]
das angenehme klima bringt höhere
erträge auf den feldern verbessert die
ernährung der fünf millionen menschen
die das reich bevölkern
am ende des jahrhunderts werden es schon
zehn millionen sein
[Musik]
die meisten von ihnen siedeln an den
strömen vor allem entlang des rheins er
blühen die zentren köln speyer und mainz
unweit dieser bischofsstadt wird im
jahre 1000 98 ein mädchen namens
hildegard geboren
[Musik]
sie ist das jüngste von zehn kindern
ihre eltern bewirtschaften einen herrn
auf
[Musik]
aber wer eigentlich nicht
mädchen träumst du schon wieder
und ich zeige dir wie man spinnt
das musst du später alles mal können
dein herr wird von mir erwarten dass du
die märkte anweisen kannst verstehst du
mein herz wer ist denn mein herr du
wirst schon sehen
[Musik]
hildegard war eine adlige das waren
vielleicht ein oder zwei prozent der
gesellschaft aber das waren diejenigen
frauen die noch eine kleine wahl hatten
das heißt die wahl bestand darin
entweder zu heiraten und das wurde nach
interessen der familie getan nicht nach
liebe und gefühl und das andere war ins
kloster zu gehen
über die frauen des mittelalters wissen
wir wenig die kaiserinnen sind bekannter
wie theophanu die frau ottos des zweiten
oder beatrix von burgund die ihr mann
friedrich barbarossa so verehrte die
meisten frauen aber bleiben namenlos
verbringen ihr leben zwischen feld und
familien
[Musik]
wegen der hohen sterblichkeit im
kindbett wurde eine deutsche im
mittelalter durchschnittlich nicht
einmal halb so alt wie heute ein
vorgezeichnete weg so scheint es
doch dann geschieht etwas das hinter
ganzes leben in andere bahnen lenkt in
ihrer vita steht
ich sah ihn so großes licht dass meine
seele erzählte aber wegen meiner
kindlichkeit vermochte ich nichts davon
vorzubringen
unerklärliche binder und visionen
begleiten sie von nun an sind es zeichen
des himmels
[Musik]
überall im reich ist der glaube das
zentrum des lebens
es ist eine zeit in der die liebe gottes
wichtiger ist als die liebe zur familie
der schöpfer ist da gegenwärtig tag und
nacht in alltag und feiertag
bei kindern und alten
die furcht vor dem fegefeuer ist so
verbreitet wie heute die angst vor
todbringende krankheit
wer ohne den segen der kirche stirbt ist
überzeugt bis in alle ewigkeit im
höllenfeuer zu schmoren
nur wer gottgefällig lebe finde aufnahme
ins paradies
[Musik]
hildegards eltern haben entschieden dass
die tochter ein leben ganz für gott
führen soll
an allerheiligen 1112 findet sie
aufnahme im benediktinerkloster
disibodenberg in südlichen und zurück
über ihren lebensweg wird von nun an der
abt bestimmen
das ist unsere tochter hildegard sie
möchte dem herrn dienen der herr möge
dieses mädchen prüfen und es als opfer
annehmen wir nehmen dich an hildegard
sei dem herrn gefällig und gehorchen für
dich beginnt heute ein neuer
lebensabschnitt
und nun nimmt abschied voneinander
[Musik]
wichtig für uns
leb wohl mein kind
und jetzt gehen
[Musik]
kein kontakt mehr zur außenwelt ein
leben in totana abgeschiedenheit beginnt
so behauptet zumindest die überlieferung
doch ganz so war es nicht also wir
müssen da abstrahieren von unserer sicht
der dinge als ob das kloster ein
gefängnis war oder etwas wo frauen in
einer ganz strengen klausur waren das
war etwas was sich erst nach hildegards
tod entwickelt hat hildegard ist nicht
allein von beginn an bei ihr ist jutta
von sponheim eine formulierte acht jahre
älter als das mädchen 25 jahre werden
die beiden gemeinsam im kloster
verbringen immer mehr junge mädchen
schließen sich ihnen an
sie beten und studieren ein kleiner
konvent aus adligen frauen entsteht
in diesen ruhigen jahren muss hildegard
einen großteil ihrer außergewöhnlichen
bildung erworben haben
noch ist sie eine folgsame nonne die
sich ihrer oberen der magistrat jutta
voigt
im hause des herrn darf ich nun für
lange zeit
[Musik]
rechtlich sind die frauen die männer
kloster disibodenberg unterstellt mehr
als 80 manche leben hier bis auf
gelegentliche besuche streng abgeschirmt
von den frauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
noch heute bieten die ruinen auf dem
disibodenberg einen imposanten anblick
der erzbischof von mainz hatte das
kloster an der nahe erheblich ausbauen
lassen
vor ort lässt sich manches noch immer in
seiner ursprünglichen funktion erkennen
überreste von bibliothek und
aufenthaltsräumen die kleine kirche an
der sich vermutlich auch die frauen
klausel befand
[Musik]
ein gigantischer backofen der bis zu 100
menschen mit brot versorgen konnte und
die überreste des hospizes für die
kranken dass ein jahrhundert nach
hildegard entstand
die früheste bestimmen das geistige und
wirtschaftliche leben im reich sie sind
die größten unternehmen ihre ländereien
umfassten ganze regionen
manche apps sind mächtiger als fürsten
und herzöge
sie unterstehen direkt dem römisch
deutschen kaiser und nicht in
landesherrn doch ihre größte bedeutung
sie stiften kultur
die geistlichen einrichtungen haben das
bildungs monopol
hier wird wissen erworben und verbreitet
jahrhunderte vor der erfindung des
buchdrucks muss jedes buch per hand
geschrieben oder kopiert werden
[Musik]
zehntausende deutsche verbringen ihr
leben in klöstern sie leben nach der
regel die benedikt von nursia der vater
des europäischen mönchtums im sechsten
jahrhundert aufgestellt hat ihr alltag
besteht aus beten und arbeiten
ora et labora
den tag teilt das sogenannte chorgebet
17 wortgottesdienste zwischen dem
morgengrauen und der dämmerung
das verlangt disziplin wie aber
pünktlich sein
das mittelalter kennt keine uhrzeiten er
braucht sie nicht denn es gibt keine
präzisen termine die länge der stunden
hängt vom tagesbeginn abgezählt werden
zwölf gleich lange stunden und somit im
dunklen winter eine stunde gerade mal 40
minuten
gemessen wird die zeit mit sonnenuhren
für den tag oder wasseruhren für die
nacht zu hildegard zeiten wird das
stundenglas erfunden manchmal ist es mit
gemahlenen eierschalen gefüllt daher der
name eieruhr aus der frommen
notwendigkeit tag wie nacht die
gebetszeiten pünktlich einzuhalten
kommen dann später in klöstern und
stiften die ersten mechanischen
turmuhren auf
[Musik]
dass benedikt ihrer kloster auf dem
disibodenberg gehört zu den
fortschrittlichsten anlagen seinerzeit
erhalten sind teile von steinernen
wasserleitungen die das kloster
ausfiltert zisternen mit frischwasser
versorgen
als hildegard 1112 auf dem disibodenberg
sie landet sie in einer baustelle erst
nach und nach errichten die mönche einer
30 meter breite und 52 meter lange
kirche fast so groß wie der dom von
mainz es entstehen wohn und
wirtschaftsräume eine stadt in kleinen
die alles bietet was eine gemeinschaft
braucht auch schutz durch eine mächtige
klostermauer
ein doppel kloster wie das auf dem
disibodenberg legt auf räumliche
trennung zwischen den geschlechtern
größten wert
[Musik]
mehr als platonische beziehungen zu den
männlichen kloster bewohnern sind streng
verboten
der verzicht auf alle leiblichen genüsse
soll den geist frei machen für die nähe
gottes das auspeitschen des körpers soll
die geißelung christi nachfüllen lassen
so versteht hildegards oberen jutta von
sponheim ihren glauben
[Musik]
jutta von sponheim ist kein einzelfall
die jahre zu beginn des zwölften
jahrhunderts sind geprägt von einem
allgemeinen religiös aufschwung die
massen wurden erfasst von dem religiösen
reform gedankengut und hunderte von
klöstern und stiften sind damals
entstanden
das führt dazu dass es auch zu einer
konkurrenz zwischen den verschiedenen
richtungen kommt und führt auch zu einer
ganz eklatanten radikalisierung in
diesen bewegungen
[Musik]
es ist auch die zeit der kreuzzüge
tausende europäer verlassen ihre heimat
und kämpfen im heiligen land für die
vorherrschaft der christen
1136 stirbt jutta von sponheim ihre
mitschwestern bereiten die waschung der
leiche vor und entdecken einen busch
viertel mit dem sich die oberen über
jahre selbst gast hat
[Musik]
wie müsste sehen
der herr will nicht dass wir unseren
leib zerstören
ich glaube das war einerseits ein trauma
für die junge hildegard und es hat dazu
geführt ganz typisch dass sie sich sagte
das will ich nicht ich will den menschen
nicht mit askese belasten und im lasten
auflagen die er nicht tragen kann
sie ist glaube ich ein kern für die
menschenfreundliche theologie und des
menschen freundlich will bitte hildegard
entstanden in der abnabelung von ihrer
meisterin
hildegard wird users nachfolgerin als
magistra der frauen fast vier jahrzehnte
lebt sie mittlerweile auf dem
disibodenberg ein menschenalter in jener
zeit
[Musik]
probiere diese während schwester
wir sind einfach christen
doch in einem alter in dem eine frau
damals meist schon mit dem leben
abgeschlossen hat beginnt gerade erst
hildegards karriere schwester wir werden
bald einen neuen garten anlegen viel
größer und schöner als diesen magistrat
ich meine wir sollten zufrieden sein mit
dem was der herr uns gegeben hat
ja lasst uns bescheiden bleiben und dem
herrn danken magistra danke dem herrn
für seine wundervolle schöpfer aber
nehmt sie gar nicht wahr
schaut was der herr uns großes geschenk
es gibt noch so viel zu entdecken
genutzt eine sünde magistrat versteht er
dass er nicht
nein das würde ich nicht verstehen
[Musik]
atmet und schmeckt die wunder des 11
hildegard muss sich während dieser jahre
ein verblüffendes wissen um die natur
vor allem die pflanzen ihrer umgebung
angeeignet haben
das sind wohl auch die jahre in denen
die grundlagen der schriften entstehen
die den ruhm hildegards bis heute
begründen sie sammelt und deutet das
wissen ihrer zeit über heilkräuter und
nahrungsmittel
aber sie befasst sich auch mit tieren
und selbst mit steinen
pause das buch von den krankheiten und
ihren heilungen und physiker die schrift
ihrer medizinischen rezepturen
[Musik]
hildegards medizinische kenntnisse sind
bis heute legendär
die forschungsgruppe klostermedizin der
universität würzburg will das heilwissen
des mittelalters wieder beleben
in den schriften hildegards von bingen
finden sie immer wieder neue alte
wirkstoffe
die hildegard eine echte ausnahme
stellung ein denn sie verbindet
religiöse theologische vorstellungen mit
mit medizinischen vorstellungen und auch
wieder und volkstümlichen vorstellungen
also diese mixtur ist wirklich ganz
einmalig auch in der klostermedizin 1140
vier jahre nachdem sie magistral
geworden ist beschließt hildegard das
geheimnis zu lüften dass ihr gesamtes
leben begleitet hat
sie behauptet visionen zu haben
wundersame dinge zu sehen visionen
und was um himmels willen sie ziehen
[Musik]
immer wieder so behauptet hildegard
verändere sich ihre wahrnehmung und sie
empfange offenbarungen vom himmel als
ich 42 jahre und sieben monate alt war
sah ich ein überaus starkes feuriges
licht aus dem geöffneten himmel kommen
ist durch strömte meinem geist mein herz
und meine brust ganz und da gleich einer
flamme die jedoch nicht brennt sondern
erwärmt sr glühte mich wie die sonne und
plötzlich hatte ich die einsicht in sinn
und auslegung der psalter und des
evangeliums des alten und des neuen
testaments und ich hörte eine stimme vom
himmel zu mir sprechen rede also von
diesem wunderbaren den
in wochenlanger arbeit ritzt sie die
worte in einer wachstafeln
argument wäre viel zu teuer gewesen erst
die reinschrift bei der ihr ein mönche
und eine nonne behilflich sind wird mit
tinte auf pergament übertragen
des keepers übersetzt wisse die wege ist
hildegard erste schrift in der sie 26
visionen beschreibt sie legt die
heilsgeschichte aus die geschichte der
schöpfung der erlösung und das ende der
zeiten
[Musik]
sie sagt der herr selbst spreche durch
ihren mund gottes wort durch den mund
eines weibes was man jetzt die vom
teufel besessen
die wege des herrn sind unergründlich
bruder voll machen und er schaut selbst
auf die niedrigste seine märkte
[Musik]
doch hätten wir wirklich eine seherin in
unserem kloster könnte das von nutzen
sein
ein kloster bedeutete damals einen
ungeheuren wirtschaftsfaktor wenn eine
anlage nonne ins kloster ging wurde sie
die braut christi und sie brachte dem
kloster sozusagen eine mitgift mit und
das waren in diesem fall damals
ländereien mühlen dörfer alles dinge die
für ein kloster und sein fortbestand
wirtschaftlich sehr wichtig waren
hildegard fähigkeiten sprechen sich
herum und machen das bis dahin kaum
bekannte kloster berühmt für den up ist
hildegard ein wertvolles pfund mit dem
er wuchern kann
doch auch die neue weiß was sie wert ist
sie zieht die zahlungskräftigen
novizinnen an wie ein magnet
jede will von der frau unterrichtet
werden die offenbar in direktem kontakt
zu gott steht
schwester hildegard
was für dich zu mir der selbst der meine
wege leitet
[Musik]
der herr selbst sagst du meine
schwestern und ich werden diese
bodenwert verlassen
gott hat uns einen neuen platz
zugewiesen
wir werden ein frauenkloster gründen
ihr glaubt dass ich euch gehen lassen
ja
erstens gehen ihr habt das gelübde
abgelegt venedigs regel verlangt corsa
von euch die regel benedikt ist mir
heilig wie dir doch benedikt selbst hat
die gründung neuer künstler immer
befürwortet
wir werden gehen was willst du dir
eigentlich ein
das lebendige licht das zu mir spricht
hat mir befohlen zu gehen
[Musik]
hätte dort
verärgert ich nicht genug nicht jeder
der ein licht sieht ist ein prophet
ihr werdet nicht geht
noch hat hildegard sich zu fügen sie ist
im amt gehorsam schuldig doch verfügt
sie über eine waffe gegen die keine
macht der welt etwas ausrichten kann
[Musik]
die stimme des allerhöchsten gott habe
sie aufgefordert zu sprechen wie die
propheten des alten testaments ist das
wahre offenbarung oder der raffinierter
trick einer frau die sich ansonsten
nicht gehör verschaffen kann
[Musik]
die moderne wissenschaft ist skeptisch
sie vermutet hinter einigen von
hildegards bildern er einen drogenrausch
der kräuter kundigen die alraune
beispielsweise eine sache her
sagenumwobene pflanze hat die nonne
intensiv beschrieben
die hildegard wusste dass alraune
magische vorstellungen erfolg dass sie
selbst sagt man muss die alraune erst
mal einen tag lang in frischem
quellwasser wässern als wirklichen die
quelle das so dass dieses die
inhaltsstoffe weggezogen werden als dann
könnte man sie innerlich verwenden ohne
wahnvorstellungen zu bekommen aber hat
sie sich auch selbst daran gehalten
auch naturwissenschaftliche
erklärungsansätze wurden gesucht so
erinnern manche bilder an die grüne
beschreibungen anderen sogenannte harlos
seltenen lichteffekte in der natur
religionswissenschaftliche sehen sind
visionen eine ganz normale form der
wirklichkeit erfahrung in ganz ganz
vielen religionen vor allen dingen auch
im christentum sind unmittelbare gottes
erfahrungen von anfang an dabei
[Musik]
zwei weitere große schriften wird
hildegard bis zu ihrem lebensende
verfassen
denn nie bei wie territorium und dem
lieber divino robe rum
[Musik]
ein begriff ist zentrum all ihrer
schriften veritas die grünen kraft
sie ist der zentrale motor der die
schöpfung den ewigen kreislauf von
werden und vergehen aufrecht erhält
[Musik]
und so manche textpassagen wird das
höhere hildegard die schattenseiten
unserer moderne beschreiben
immer wieder so die visionärin greife
der mensch in den kosmos ein und die
natur antworte mit einem wilden schrei
wie die elemente die lüfte die wasser
wir stinken schon wie die pest
alle wände sind von mode und die
luftspalt so viel schmutz aus dass die
menschen kaum noch wagen ihren mund
aufzumachen
die hellseherei hat es wohl wenig zu tun
man kann vielleicht sagen es liegt an
einer bestimmten welt sich ziele ganz
entscheidend aber dürfte sein dass
hildegard durchaus die veränderungen in
ihrer eigenen zeit erkannt hat
umweltverschmutzung ist nicht nur ein
phänomen unserer zeit auch in ihrer zeit
waren flüsse verschmutzt wurden wälder
abgeholzt darauf ziehen wohl diese sätze
ab und man wird vielleicht sagen können
hildegard war so etwas wie eine erste
grüne die alte klausel auf dem
disibodenberg ist längst zu klein auch
um hildegard zu halten lässt er abt eine
neue erheblich größere born mit räumen
für bedienstete und einem wohnturm
die neue klausel hat einen eigenen
eingang durch die klostermauer denn
hildegard wissen sieht auch die menschen
der umgebung an
[Musik]
die nonnen sind als hebammen hoch
geschätzt und erfahren dabei auch
manches was für frauen ruhen so gar
nicht gerecht erscheint
[Musik]
das achte wenn ich richtig gezählt habe
eigentlich schon das elfte 3 hat der
herr gleich wieder zu sich genommen
doch mein mann und ich wir können
einfach nicht voneinander lassen
dann werden der nachbarn einander liegen
dann wird es hier unten ganz war als
würde ein feuer in mir lodern ein
gewaltiges feuer gegen dass ich mich
nicht wehren können so ist es bestimmt
wenn man den himmel schaut und die engel
des herrn leuten dann singen sie nur für
mich ich fühle mich leicht wie eine
feder und schwebe über ein meer von
blumen seien keine blumen eigentlich
sind es viele lichter viele bunte
lichter die mich umkreisen und zustand
von irene hilgert die wohl erste
schriftliche darstellung des weiblichen
orgasmus
als würde ein mann eine faust mit aller
kraft zusammendrücken
[Musik]
dass eine frau so darüber schreibt ist
etwas ganz ungewöhnliches
und sie bringt es aber immer in den
zusammenhang mit liebe auch das ist ja
wirklich erstaunlich denn die
katholische theologie bis in unsere zeit
war ja eigentlich der meinung dass
sexualität vor allem mit fortpflanzung
zu tun hat nein sie schreibt von liebes
umarmungen
das heißt der grund ihrer theologie gott
ist die liebe nimmt der körper nicht aus
und das darf man ohne weiteres als
modern und zeitgemäß schülern doch eine
revolutionärin in gesellschaftlicher
hinsicht ist sie nicht aber hitze und
anstrengung sind vorerst nichts für dich
und hier von drei mal am tag ein aufguss
ja aber schaffen muss sich weiter ich
muss ja die hungrigen mäuler stopfen
elisabeth
wenn ihr doch meine tochter elisabeth
als novizin nehmen könnte
aber ich habe dir doch schon gesagt dass
wir die kleine nicht nehmen können es
tut mir leid
warum denn nicht sie ist ein
bauernmädchen aber sie ist noch trotzdem
ein kind gottes
[Musik]
der niedrige stand soll sich nicht über
den höheren erheben wir sind von aden
oder würdest du ochsen und pferde schafe
und esel in einen einzigen stein sperren
es ist schon alles gut so wie es ist
hildegard meint ist auch so gemeint ist
auch in vielen sonstiger hinsicht so
dass eben der mensch an dem platz
bleiben soll wie gott ihn hingestellt
hat also gegen soziale mobilität gegen
aufstiegs prozesse die sie in ihrer zeit
sehr gut beobachten konnte doch ihr
mächtiger und bekannter sie wird umso
stärker ist auch die kritik an hildegard
eine konkurrierende äbtissin beklagt in
einem geharnischten brief
mir ist ungewöhnliches zu ohren gekommen
nämlich dass eure jungen frauen an
festtagen beim seinen gesang mit losen
haaren in der kirche stehen
hildegard legt die regeln aus wie sie
will eine zumutung in einer zeit in der
jede abweichung verdächtig macht auch in
rom will man wissen ob auf dem
disibodenberg gegen die regeln der
kirche verstoßen wird
im herbst 1147 erreicht eine
untersuchungskommission das kloster der
bischof von werder soll den fall im
auftrag des papstes prüfen
was hört und sieht hildegard in ihrem
visionen darf sie weiter ihre schriften
verbreiten
[Musik]
wir haben merkwürdiges von euch gehört
und sind ziemlich erstaunt um es
vorsichtig auszudrücken
deshalb frage ich euch könnte es nicht
sein das ist träume sind die ihr in
eurem weiblichen und verstand für
visionen haltet ich schlafe nicht
ich bin immer wachen geistes wenn das
lebendige licht zu mir spricht so waren
wie ich es jetzt bin
man sagt ihr schreibt bisweilen einer
unverständlichen sprache die nur ihr
selbst zu verstehen in der lage sein
wer gibt durch diese worte ein
die allmächtige nur eine spielerei
ehrwürdiger bischof
eine spielerei ohne bedeutung eine
spielerei link nota ist die wohl
geheimnisvollsten hinterlassenschaft
hildegard in der hessischen
landesbibliothek sind die meisten
schriften in wiesbadener riesen kodex
erhalten
der experte für mittelalterliche
schriften michael embach erforscht die
linke eck note die unbekannte sprache
wie sie das mittelalter nennt auf fünf
seiten erscheinen wörter einer reizen
haften sprache mit ihren lateinischen
und deutschen übersetzung
[Musik]
hier ist der bart mal ski der zahl
beelitz der teufel
auffällig ist dabei dass ausschließlich
substantive vermittelt werden und
substantive adjektive das heißt es
fehlen sämtliche bestandteile einer
sprache die grammatik bilden könnten die
syntax bilden könnten
und das bedeutet dass diese sprache
diese künstliche sprache nicht
gesprochen werden konnte
noch bizarrer ist der nächste eintrag
ein komplettes alphabet seltsame zeichen
mit ihren lateinischen entsprechungen in
dieser schrift schrieb hildegard an
befreundete klöster wollte man so
geheime botschaften übermitteln wohl
nicht historiker sehen die sache
gelassen ich denke dass diese sprache
diese künstliche sprache ein ein licht
wirft auf die kreativität hildegards auf
ihre fantasie mit der sprache handhaben
konnte das ist ein enormer kreativer akt
der hinter einer solchen sprache steht
und das verdient natürlich alle
anerkennung
er war ziemlich hoch hinaus nein ich bin
nur eine niedrige mag die unserem herrn
folgt und sein wort verkündet
[Musik]
die schriften gottes auszulegen diese
anmaßung steht einem weit nicht zu aber
der herr selbst gab mir diesen auftrag
[Musik]
aus dem geöffneten himmel fuhr blitzend
ein feuriges licht hernieder es
durchdrang mein geist und setzte mein
herz gleich einer flamme in brand und
plötzlich offenbarten sich mir die
schriften die bezahlte und die
evangelien
ich habe genug gehört er würde gehabt
ich werde dem heiligen vater bericht
erstatten
die gelegenheit dazu bietet sich als
papst eugen der dritte nach trier kommt
[Musik]
mein lieber bischof von werde wie im
fall dieser nonne bericht erstatten
was hat eure befragung des weibes
ergeben
[Musik]
ist die wahrhaftig des teufels und st
für hilde da steht alles auf dem spiel
wie wird der papst entscheiden sieht er
in ihr die heilige oder die tänzerin auf
einem großen eisen farbigen berg runter
ein licht erwischt schreibt sie hier das
seine herrlichkeit meine augen blendete
und sie erklärte diese vision sie sei
die posaune gottes behauptet sind
welch eine anmaßung
ist es tatsächlich gottvater der sich
durch die äußert dann wäre sie eine
große prophet hin und da spricht der
leibhaftige aus hier
sondern erlöse unternehmen
[Musik]
teufel besessen sie ist von gott
auserwählt
sie lästert gott
[Musik]
rahmen des allmächtigen gottes dessen
stellvertreter ich auf erden bin völlig
nun das urteil über die magistra
hildegard gott der herr hat großes hat
dieser frau getan
der teufel hat keine macht über sie
sie wurde von gott erwählt und wir
sollten auf ein wort hören
[Musik]
so steht der verlauf der geschichte in
hildegards vita die sie maßgeblich
selbst formuliert hat dafür gibt es
keinerlei schriftliche quellen und man
weiß dass schon damals der vatikan eine
sehr fortschrittliche behörde war die
haben alles aufgeschrieben
also wenn es das so gewesen wäre dann
hätte man das in den akten gefunden hat
man nicht die historiker sind sich aber
eigentlich dass in dieser zeit wo die
mündliche überlieferung noch so groß war
der papst offensichtlich informiert
worden ist und mündlich gesagt hat
erhält das was da geschieht für positiv
hildegard die meisterin der
selbstdarstellung hat also aus einer
guten geschichte eine noch besser
gemacht
die päpstliche anerkennung gibt ihr die
macht auf die sie gewartet hat der abt
vom disibodenberg muss ihn schließlich
ziehen lassen 1151 verlässt hildegard
mit ihren nonnen den berg vier
jahrzehnte hat sie doch dem kloster
verbracht ein ganzes leben und doch nur
der auftakt zur erfolgsgeschichte der
nonne hildegard die in späteren zeiten
von bingen genannt wird
denn dort will sie ein neues kloster tor
würden diese boden berg beginnt mit dem
auszug der niedergang
die chronik des klosters endet abrupt
[Musik]
hildegard hat ihr ziel erreicht sie kann
die provinz verlassen und dorthin ziehen
wo die nachrichtenströme des reiches
zusammenlaufen
am zusammenfluss von rhein und nahe
bauen die nonnen ihr kloster rupertsberg
von nun an wird hildegard auch den
mächtigen trotzen
in hunderten briefen wettert sie gegen
die gottlosigkeit der herrschenden auch
den neuen könig friedrich barbarossa am
mahnt sie der blindheit einer augen die
nicht richtig sehen wie du dass deine
augen die nicht richtig sehen wie du das
zepter zum rechten regieren in deiner
hand halten muss
für hildegard beginnt ihr zweiter
öffentlicher lebensabschnitt in ihrer
vita ist von predigt reisen ins gesamte
reich die rede wenn auch ein teil der
briefe und berichte über hildegard
erfolge heute von der forschung
angezweifelt wird
einmal ist sie barbarossa und seiner
frau wirklich begegnet 1154 stellt der
könig rupertsberg in ingelheim unter
seinen persönlichen schutz
fortan ist sie nur noch barbarossa und
den papst verantwortlich
hildegard von bingen stirbt mit damals
fabelhaften 80 jahren
ihre gebeine liegen bis heute in der
pfarrkirche von bingen wenige jahrzehnte
nach ihrem tod beginnen die neuen ihrer
heiligsprechung zu beantragen
doch sie scheiterten daran rum zu
überzeugen offiziellen heilig ist
hildegard bis heute nicht
[Musik]
einmal im jahr wird ihr schreien durch
den ort rüdesheim am rhein und die
weinberge getragen
die nonnen der dortigen abtei die von
hildegard begründet wurde
kriegen die erinnerung an die große
äbtissin mit kirchen lehrerin an eine
seherin und visionärin deren lehrern
heute mehr menschen faszinierenden je
[Musik]
und an eine frau die nicht nur aus ihrer
zeit heraus ragte
[Musik]
ein wind blies von einem hohenberg und
brachte mit seinem wen eine kleine feder
in bewegung die aus sich selbst
keinerlei fähigkeit zum fliegen besaß
sondern diese nur durch den wind empfing
zweifellos veranlasste dies der
allmächtige gott um zu zeigen was er
durch ein wesen das von sich nicht das
geringste sich zutrauen würde zu wirken
vermag
die verfasserin dieser zeilen war die
einflussreichste frau ihrer zeit aus
eigener kraft heraus und gegen alle
widerstände
[Musik]
[Applaus]